this half gallon of whole milk from Aldi
cost
$218 eggs $187 bread1 129 Aldi is the
fastest growing grocer by store count in
the country and its No Frills approach
has also made it one of the cheapest for
the past decade it's been growing at a
rate of about 100 stores per year and
when an economic downturn hits it
thrives it's about Simplicity and it's
about efficiency and it's about uh
consistent experience all the time this
is the economics of
Aldi so how does the company keep its
prices so low take its store setup you
walk in and the moment you step foot in
our sore you can see all four walls Aldi
are typically around 12,000 fet about
the same as a Trader Joe's and much
smaller than the average supermarket
operating a smaller space saves money
when buying the property on the lease
and on utilities the layout at Aldi is
as much designed for our operational
effic efficiency is anything and so
being very specific about the amount of
footsteps it takes to service our store
and a very limited store size allows us
to operate a very efficient operation
and that creates a lot of value to
further its efficiency Aldi doesn't have
extra services like a customer help desk
a fresh bakery or Butcher and it stocks
significantly fewer products
supermarkets typically carry around
31,000 products Trader Joe's has about 4
,000 but Aldi stalks about
1,600 often there are just three to five
employees on the sales floor so having
fewer items and leaving them in the
boxes they were delivered in means
employees spend less time stocking
shelves these cost cutting strategies
are critical to Aldi's profit margin and
they're why the company is able to offer
items that are cheaper than the national
average but they also serve another
purpose they help maintain Aldi's image
as a Discount Store customers make
compensatory inferences basically
marketing experts say when people see an
item's price they quickly make
assumptions about the product if it's
cheap they may assume its lower quality
which is why Aldi's No Frill strategy is
so effective from the moment customers
put quarters in their carts and walk
into the store they can see all the ways
Aldi reduces costs marketing experts say
these tactics all signal to the customer
that milk eggs and bread are cheaper at
Aldi because of its efficiency rather
than its quality though the results of
its cost cutting strategies aren't
always popular with customers in a
survey of roughly 6,500 people Aldi
scored on par with or slightly lower
than many of its peers in categories
like store cleanliness and item
availability but there's another key
tactic Grocers use to Aid their lowcost
images known value items these are
staple household products whose prices
people often remember as Ali has
expanded across the country other
groceries have reduced their prices in
response particularly on these types of
items when Aldi comes in it prompts
other retailers to look at their prices
again and kind of you know surgically
examine how to adjust what they sell and
for how much that's because when people
see lower prices for staple Goods they
infer that the business offers low
prices all around and when it comes to
value for dollar Aldi r highest in the
customer survey at
96% but stores can only compete on price
so much without hurting their profit
margins so what does Aldi use other than
price point to draw customers it's
private label items 90% of Aldi stock is
private label like its other strategies
this reduces costs for the company we
take all of our buying power and we put
into the seven most popular or common
salad dressings that a customer might
buy that allows us to deal directly with
manufacturers and make sure that we get
the best cost price analysts say that
Trader Joe's uses private label items to
differ from competitors by creating
items that customers can only find there
like it's Ube Mochi pancake mix and
butternut squash mac and cheese but at
Aldi you'll find private label items
that look quite similar to the most
well-known National Brands instead of
Wheat Thins Ali has thin wheat according
to analysts this is because Ali wants
customers to think they're essentially
getting the same product but at a
significant discount there was a time
when the perception was you know they're
the generic brand and you know they're
just cheaper but not as good as the
national Brands and those days are over
as consumers felt the lasting impacts of
inflation sales of storebrand products
increased from 2018 to 2022 there was a
34% increase in industrywide private
label sales totaling more than 57
billion ion dollar while some other
Grocers might have private label
offerings this is the existence of what
we do Aldi has Thrive during recessions
the 2008 financial crisis sparked its
growth and decision to add around 100
new stores per year what was really
interesting is we never lost any of
those customers and as the economy
improved and we had a really long run of
economic Improvement Aldi grew
throughout that entire period of time
and now as inflation drains Americans
wallets Aldi continues to grow in the
beginning that was sort of their target
audience people who you know wanted
Bargains and wanted to buy food for for
low prices but in recent years I think
they've really expanded that audience to
also go after people who want
convenience shopping who want the
necessities and want to be in and out of
[Music]
stores